chacun dit on fait la ronde des vins
sans sortir du salon et cette année on
recense de route voilà et cette année on
a décidé de commencer par la chance et
croyez moi il vaut mieux nous avoir
rendez-vous galant à l'aube à tous aubin
pour le boulot j'ai l'impression qu'il
commence à faire des siennes
ah bah j'ai une semaine de vacances par
an j'ai tout cas demi on va la faire
faire route des vins brunner c'est quoi
votre prénom
mike après l'autre acteur américain
la douce tout va bien j'ai une bonne et
une mauvaise nouvelle
la mauvaise c'est j'ai recommencé à
boire mais la très belle séquence suis
rapproché bruno le taquet de paravent je
regarde à ce qu'il faut pas trop c'est
la galère a été fort je me trompe et
fermés ça leur parle et ça c'est ce
qu'elle préfère
mais je vois plein de bonnes choses un
cdi dans peu de temps avec vous je me
sois pas du tout dans l'ailleurs à
l'arrière d'une voiture
au fait je vais simplement vous signaler
que mon compteur affiche 2654 euros pour
la ferme mais travail j'arrive à le
courage
enfin faut pas que je m'énerve faut pas
que madame bretons et la ponctuation
autour construit ce cadre elle voit
comme nous tous
gaillac et c'est bon c'est le porte la
pente est un paquebot
c'est gentil et vous sait comment
voteront venus j'ai un petit pouilly
fuissé 2011
faut prendre le temps pour le déguster
c'est quelque chose qui s'appréciaient
pas sur la longueur je n'ai pas de prix
du chasseur